we are meeting someone who earns his
money by smuggling people across the
English Channel his insights are
extraordinary for one thing telling me
British police need to start looking
much closer to home
we've obscured his identity and his
voice
is
foreign
[Music]
some claim the French are not doing
enough to stop these Crossings but The
Smuggler told us that in fact it was
getting harder
foreign
[Music]
at least 45
000 migrants arrived in Britain on these
boats last year most of them claiming
Asylum
the Prime Minister says it's a major
priority to stop these Crossings to
thwart the people Smugglers
would it make a difference if people
were sent to Rwanda when they arrived as
the government as the British government
has threatened to do this
would that change the business model
Amazon
um
on the beach the remains of a failed
crossing the boat's engine broke down
the passengers fled and the police have
now slashed the stingy so it can't be
used again we do see a sign of Greater
cooperation between the UK and France
more intelligence is being shared but
there are none of the promised British
offices on view here
we were not the only people watching
that boat full of migrants heading to
Britain a French surveillance plane
circled overhead a French naval vessel
trailed behind but there's very little
the authorities can do to stop a boat
once it's in the water and not calling
for help
for the French and British governments
this is the result of organized crime
Brazen illegality but the Smugglers
don't see it that way
foreign
we discover that smuggling like so much
else is all about supply and demand
foreign
[Music]
has pledged to stop small boats like
this one by breaking the model of people
smuggling he is determined to succeed
but so are the Smugglers who send ever
more people across the channel and at
the moment they do seem to be winning
Adam Parsons Sky News northern France